alors que les clients se font rares les
restaurateurs se tourner vers les
commandes pour emporter toutes les
poursuites sont compostables et comme
dans les verres mais pour en mairie va
pas question d'utiliser du plastique
on essaye de faire la guerre aux
plastiques afin de lutter contre la
pollution et de réduire les 3 millions
de tonnes de plastique que les canadiens
jette à la poubelle chaque année ottawa
aussi veut faire la guerre aux
plastiques l'interdiction des plastiques
à usage unique difficile à recycler et
pour lesquels il existe d autres motifs
les pailles et les bâtonnets de café les
ustensiles les contenants nourriture et
les sacs de plastiques seront bannis
d'ici la fin de 2021
un petit peu faible les
environnementalistes sont déçus que le
gouvernement ne s'attaque pas aux
bouteilles de plastique ni ou gobelets à
café la tasse et le couvercle table par
exemple sont parmi les déchets les plus
retrouver dans les sites d'enfouissement
et dans l'environnement
le ministre reconnaît à mots couverts
que la mesure est modeste ce1 petite
partie de notre plan non je ne crois pas
du tout que c'est trop timide mais
ottawa se défend d'avoir manqué
d'ambition l'idée ultime ans et qu'un
déchet dans un avenir pas trop lointain
ça n'existe plus que tous les produits
que nous utilisons nous puissions soit
les recyclés soit les composter ottawa
souhaite éliminer tous les déchets
plastiques d'ici 2030
l'alberta crains que ça nuise à son
industrie pétrolière
une frange de l'industrie du plastique
aussi s'inquiète pour son avenir
la majorité des producteurs c'est des
petites et moyennes entreprises au
québec et peuvent avoir un impact de
jusqu'à 1 4000 emplois dirais pour
certains restaurateurs remplacer le
plastique par des produits recyclables
ou compostables comportera des défis
c'est ce qui a un coût
mais en même temps si ça devient
obligatoire et qui a plus de plastique
le couvert bc à mon avis ottawa a voulu
satisfaire les environnementalistes mais
sans trop déplaire à l'industrie un
exercice que les libéraux ont souvent
essayé mais qu'ils n'ont pas toujours
trouvé simples à réaliser ici christian
noël radio canada ottawa